THAT WERE MADE FOR TEAM CLINTON
DURING THE INVESTIGATIONS INTO
HER PRIVATE SERVER.
JOINING US NOW IS THE PRESIDENT
OF JUDICIAL WATCH TOM FITTON.
AS THE FORMER CHAIRMAN OF THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE, NO ONE DID
BETTER WORK THAN JUDICIAL WATCH
AND TOM FITTON.
TOM, EXPLAINED TO US WHAT YOU
JUST UNCOVERED IN THESE NEW
EMAILS THAT YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO
SEE?
>> THESE ARE STRUCK PAGE EMAILS,
EMAILS THAT WE'VE BEEN GETTING S
EMAILS THAT WE'VE BEEN GETTING O
EMAILS THAT WE'VE BEEN GETTING L
EMAILS THAT WE'VE BEEN GETTING Y
EMAILS THAT WE'VE BEEN GETTING F
EMAILS THAT WE'VE BEEN GETTING O
EMAILS THAT WE'VE BEEN GETTING M
EMAILS THAT WE'VE BEEN GETTING T
EMAILS THAT WE'VE BEEN GETTING E
EMAILS THAT WE'VE BEEN GETTING F
EMAILS THAT WE'VE BEEN GETTING I
EMAILS THAT WE'VE BEEN GETTING .
AND THEY SHOWED THAT THE FBI
DURING THE CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION, GENERAL COUNSEL
BAKER WAS WORKING, BASICALLY
EATING OUT OF THE PALM OF THE
HAND OF THE LAWYER FOR CHERYL
MILLS AND HEATHER SHANE
THE TWO LAWYERS FOR
HILLARY CLINTON WHO HELPED HER
DELETE ALL THE EMAILS.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WAYS TO GET
THEM TO TESTIFY IN PLACES WHERE
THERE WON'T BE MEDIA STAKE OUTS.
THE DOCUMENTS SHOWED THEY WERE
GIVING THEM A HEADS UP PRESS
STORIES.
AND EVEN PETER STRZOK GETS FED
UP WITH THE GAMESMANSHIP.
HE NOTES THAT THEY GET TWO
LAPTOPS WHERE THEY HAVE THE
60,000 EMAILS OR WHAT USED TO BE
THE 60,000 EMAILS BECAUSE HALF
OF THEM WERE DELETED.
IT'S INTERESTING WE ARE GETTING
THEM NOW.
THIS IS IN-YOUR-FACE OBSTRUCTIO
OBSTRUCTION.
AT THE SAME TIME, YOU HAVE TO
REMEMBER THAT WHILE THEY ARE
TAKING CARE OF THE
HILLARY CLINTON -- THEY ARE
WORKING WITH HER CAMPAIGN AND
BENDING OVER BACKWARDS LATER INH
BENDING OVER BACKWARDS LATER INE
YEAR.
YOU'VE GOT FBI LAWYERS IT LOOKS
LIKE AUTHORING DOCUMENTS A
TARGET TRIM.
WHAT AN OUTRAGE.
IT'S ONE MORE PIECE OF EVIDENCE
THAT WOULD IN MY VIEW TO REOPEN
THE CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION INTO
THIS WHOLE ISSUE.
>> Jason: LOOK AT PART OF THE
EMAILS IN A MEETING WITH
McCABE.
I REMEMBER, IT WAS MCCABE'S WIFE
WHO WAS ULTIMATELY RUNNING IN A
RACE TO HELP THE CLINTONS DO A
FUND-RAISER WITH THAT MONEY
ULTIMATELY ENDS UP IN HIS WIFE'S
POCKET FOR A POLITICAL CAMPAIGN